when you write a song about a romantic
song everyone right away assumes it's
some famous woman you dated right and
they sort of part of the intrigue
there's not a lot of like interviews
where I talk a lot about like personal
stuff right but I'm fine doing in music
and I kind of feel like doing it in
music that's my version of something but
how do you feel when someone does that
to you and Taylor Swift writes a song
and everyone assumes it's about new
Harry I mean does that upset you
no no upset me I be I think I think
about what it means to me to write a
song about somebody else and for someone
else to do there I think it's like a you
know it's like flattering even if the
song isn't that flattering you've still
spent time on it and and ultimately
using Taylor as an example she's a great
songwriter so I wish some woman who
slept with me would write a song about
not one woman I ever been with no one
was moved by me sexually enough to write
a song about I know it's horrible but I
think yeah I think the only time you
really like think about oh is this song
too personal is if you think about is
this gonna be really annoying for the
other person right you know because I
you do care
yeah you don't know have you ever used
the dating app no you don't need it it
would be wrong he is a dating app yeah
you are you should start a Harry Styles
dating